this week i had a little incident
a fellow who writes to me quite often
his name is ivor cat
and i have no problem he writes to me
i think i have all his mails i archive
them usually
sometimes i answer them okay
and uh so he wrote a letter this week
and he copies several people among them
he copied me
okay and he was a professor at the uh
a couple universities he he um
both in england and in the united states
i think he worked also for motorola and
so on
well anyways uh and that's uh that's his
last name cat with two t's and that's
not schrodinger's cat by the way okay
that's a different cat so he comes up
with a cat
question okay and he says to the
recipients of this email try to get a
teacher professor or textbook writer
with the expertise in electromagnetic
theory to comment on this below okay
and worldwide they are protecting and
continue to
teach false theory i would like to add
their comments to
and he gives a sight
okay and specifically he likes to talk
about electricity
okay what is electricity that's that's
the bottom line that's
a topic i want to address with him as
well
and the issue here is the following
uh not only do the rest of the world
teach the wrong
electricity so does mr cat they
all teach the wrong or the irrational
uh electricity you say why rational well
here's here's what you get taught when
you go to uh college
okay you go to college they teach you
this so all electricians all these
people they learn the same thing
and they learn that this is a circuit
when you close the circuit well you have
electrons going around okay and they go
from atom to atom
right again we don't know what the atom
looks like it's supposed to be this
ball with a little bead at the end the
bead is especially the valence bead the
last one right that's the one that's
going to go around okay
and uh you're supposed to think of this
as iron or copper
you know more complicated atoms than
just hydrogen
okay so they have this beads going
around well the question is whether this
is electricity is this
how electric is this what's happening in
your wires in your house
and uh we have a different proposal also
under the rope model
and it goes something like this let me
get this up here
oh no well let me go one step extra
uh uh one of the irrationalities or one
of
i call it a ptolemaic explanation
and here you see why here's an ac
circuit okay
and this is what these people are
proposing they're proposing that the
polarities change you can see the
positive and negative are switched
around it's like if you
switch your your uh battery on whatever
on a clock or whatever you switch it
back and forth constantly at the speed
of light almost you know
very fast you switch it back and forth
to produce ac alternate current see the
first one was
uh uh dc the direct current this one is
ac it goes back and forth
it changes direction and uh
you know that is a ptolemaic explanation
for electricity
uh part of the problem is you know you
send it from from one
and you know it takes a long time to
arrive at the other end
you know the whether you push one
electron forward
along the series of atoms
or whether you just send one photon
electron all around
either way it takes some time to get
there and that causes some problems uh
explaining electricity especially how
electricity works
okay and uh so
how do we start well we start i'm gonna
do it with iron okay
so here's the uh iron uh the element
iron okay the iron
atom okay and you can see it's quite
complex
and according to the rope model all
those
are threads that weave balloons
those are real live balloons they are
membranes
okay so these are not orbitals
or regions or whatever no these are
actual balloons there is no electron
bead running around
it's just the balloons we're going to
look at the outer one so if you get an
idea
there it's a little ball that's got all
these things sticking out
okay so keep that in mind for a second
because i'm going to show you now
what we do with this atom we're going to
take the iron atom
okay and we're gonna build a wire with
it
that's the one on the top okay we're
gonna build a wire
and we're just gonna put all these uh
iron
uh atoms connected to each other there
we they
they blend into each other that's a long
story i've explained it in the past but
right now i just want to go on
we make this wire okay and that's a wire
there
made of iron okay just pure iron what
you see on the bottom
is that the molecules in there okay
are rotating they're all merged together
it's a long
thin very you're talking about molecular
level here
uh that's uh cross-section is just one
atom
radius you know so you're talking about
the angstrom range here
something very extremely small okay and
you got these they're rolling they're
spinning
okay they're spinning when you when you
turn on the electricity that's what i'm
gonna explain
okay so let's look at a circuit now and
you can see the iron circuit
okay and there it is when you
pull the down the switch and you have
electricity flowing
what you're doing is torquing all these
the snake that rolls around it's the
head is tied to its
head the tail okay of the snake the
whole thing is twisting on itself
okay so if you look at it from one side
you say it's
going clockwise if you look at it from
the other side it's
counterclockwise mother nature
understands clockwise and
counterclockwise
mother nature does not understand what
this positive and negative stuff that
benji franklin invented she has no clue
what what benjamin franklin was talking
about what is this positive negative
that's just mathematical gibberish here
we're talking about physics
we're saying what how does mother nature
do her trick i mean that's a physical
thing
or or are you going to put spirits in
there and say well no that's done with
concepts that's done with energy
oh if you're going to do it with energy
you're introducing concepts
undefined concepts or as mr feynman said
no one knows what energy is
okay yeah nobody knows what energy is
you gotta do it with a physical object
here you have iron
these are atoms they're all merged
together they spin
and as soon as you turn the electricity
on and that's a long story i've
explained in the past but i'm gonna go
over that now
but what it does is send it in both
directions through the tail and through
the
head of the snake that's you know coil
around
and so the snake turns in both both in
its tail in its
head at the same time okay so it's all
twirling okay
on itself okay that's electricity
according to us and so that's a little
different than the little ball that goes
all around okay we have a different
mechanism for electricity because we
have a different
proposal okay and
just in case we add one more level to
that which is an interesting point
okay and that's that as the
um atoms spin the row of atoms spins
it uh the some of the threads come loose
and they form what is called the
magnetic field
so now the magnetic field runs what 90
degrees perpendicular to the flow
flow of current so
whereas the spiral you know the
clockwise and counterclockwise you
look straight at the wire it's running
either clockwise or counterclockwise
depending on which way the current is
slowing
well the uh threads are spinning always
90 degrees to the so-called flow of
current
okay direction of current okay so uh
that explains also why magnetism runs 90
degrees to
electricity always
and they're perpendicular to each other
okay and here you see a little more
evidence proof that's this is the
religion part
okay trying to convince you here okay so
just keep that in mind we're not talking
science at this moment
you can see that at the bottom left uh
if you put a magnet under water
it collects the iron filings one at a
time
it doesn't call you know there's
something flowing in there a magnetic
field is something
in motion something in motion inside a
magnetic field
and i'm saying that those threads that
those uh
lines of force that faraday talked about
they are actually threads that are
spinning
the thread is a physical entity now now
you can do something with that you can't
do that with energy you can't do that
with
particles which are not particles or
with waves which are not even objects
you have to do with a physical object
otherwise you are in effect introducing
spirits in that same space
okay so what's the deal uh with uh
with mr cat well um
i wrote a letter back just a uh
a real quick one explaining that you
know i have a different model of
electricity
so i told them the phone said the funny
part about all your so-called dissidents
is that none of you are any different
whatsoever than the establishment you
criticize
and that you claim persecutes and
censors you
from the electric universe to the chapel
etherist to the flat earthers to the
mechanics of quantum and relativist
both special in general you are all in
the same boat as far as we're concerned
you're on the same boat because you're
in the
movement of concepts and you're pushing
particles
which are not particles some of them say
they are the the dissonance usually say
that
they're they're real particles those are
the ethers and the other guys are
non-ethers but they do ether as well
just they each one of their particles is
just
uh an abstraction okay okay so what did
uh
what happened next well we have another
gentleman come in
and he was on the list and he was a
little ticked off maybe because uh i
analyzed him in the past uh i don't know
if you remember
about a year ago i uh analyzed mr de
hillster david the hillster
and his father and uh they uh
i think they are the leaders the heads
of the john chappelle society
society i call them the john chapel
society because i think they do religion
okay and he was a little ticked off
maybe maybe because
he realized uh that i was criticizing
him indirectly or
or who knows why but he he felt a little
offended that he was on the list he
wasn't complaining against me he was
complaining yes like who put me on this
mailing list right says who creates
these male email chains whose discussion
whose discussion get lost in the
proverbial ether
yeah people hijack your email include
you in discussions without permission
and they think that
is morally okay sort of like a group of
people who open the door of your home
walk in and start discussing something
without your permission
well to some degree he's right you know
it doesn't bother me
but you know i can imagine some people
may not like
to receive emails or be included in
in know the distribution list
and so what happened next well uh what
happened
next was that um
that uh he was uh this man
ivor cat he replied and it was his reply
that i liked the most that made me
laugh and i want to share that one with
you if i can find it here it is
and he said the following he says stay
away from me okay
he said dear david my work is silenced
misrepresented i am defamed in
peer-reviewed journals
which say i am bizarre outside of
academia
and structured research and then the
next thing he says
block gady
[Laughter]
i love that one that made me laugh i
cracked up
he said black katie they're censoring me
they're censoring me but black katie
so yeah that gives you an idea how the
um we're all human
we're all human that's what it comes
down to and uh i think if the electric
universe were running the show they
would block
the the uh rotavist and uh if the flat
earthers were
running their show they would block all
of us